Olha essa aqui que deixou muita gente
preocupada. A Diamarca acabou de Denizar
pacientes que perderam parte da visão
depois de usar os pique. Será que
estamos prestando atenção nos riscos
reais desses medicamentos? Pois é, foram
quatro pessoas que desenvolveram uma
condição chamada Naon, uma neuropatia
óptica que danifica o nervo da visão de
forma irreversível. A indenização total
foi de quase R$ 700.000. E olha só, em
junho desse ano, a Agência Europeia de
Medicamentos já tinha alertado sobre
essa associação e mandou incluir esse
risco na bula. 43 pessoas já fizeram
reclamações na Dinamarca e dessas cinco
que foram analisadas, quatro foram
aprovadas paraa indenização. Agora veja
bem, o risco é estimado em até um caso a
cada 10.000 pacientes. Parece pouco, né?
Mas quando a gente fala de perda e
reversível da visão, qualquer número é
significativo. E aqui tá o ponto.
Medicamentos novos, por mais populares
que sejam, exigem uma avaliação muito
cuidadosa de risco versus benefício. A
gente não pode simplesmente sair
prescrevendo sem antes tentar métodos
mais seguros, mudança, estilo de vida e
ajustes alimentares. Então fica a
reflexão. Será que vale a pena correr
esse risco quando existem outras
alternativas mais seguras para trabalhar
o peso e a saúde metabólica?